We were just talking about a show that you got,
you and Ted Nugent.
Apparently someone did someone,
did you pitch it?
Who pitched the show?
It was an idea that uh,
my manager Heidi and I came up with,
well mostly Heidi,
it was like,
it was called basically Henry and uh,
you put me and someone I might have some disagreements with or a few agreements
with and we just go somewhere and we weigh in with a camera following us and
we're thinking w it'll be like a six part mini series like you know me and plus
six interesting people.
And one of the names that came up was ted Nugent because I am a fan of his
music.
I think he's one of the best guitar players I've ever seen yet.
He and I would probably disagree on one or a few topics and so we actually
picked,
pitched it to Ted who said he loved the idea,
but he said,
I got to go on.
I'm busy with a,
he had a ton of tour dates,
so I think he's on now.
But he said,
I want to talk to Henry to thank him for thinking of me.
Okay.
And so ted called like on my phone in the office,
I guess he got my number from the powers that be and suddenly it's,
it's Ted on my phone.
I met my desk like,
okay,
this is surreal.
And we talked for a few minutes and he said,
uh,
you know,
like,
what do you think I'm a bad guy?
I'm like,
no,
I just,
some of the things you say,
I kind of takes my breath away.
And then we quickly got on the topic of music.
He said,
you like all that old Detroit music?
I go,
yeah man.
I mean,
you,
you Mitch Ryder,
the stooges Mc five.
I mean,
it's kind of the best.
Some of the best music I've ever heard.
I mean,
as far.
And I asked him,
I go,
what is it?
Is something in the water,
what is it with the Michigan guys and guitar tone,
like no one gets tone like you,
uh,
Ron Ashton stooges,
Fred Sonic Smith,
Mc five.
I give you guys,
I mean,
you're so good.
And he said,
you gotta we gotta hang out sometime and we'll just talk about music.
I want,
I'll do that with you.
So I'll be taking notes.
And he was just telling me,
you know,
like yeah,
he used to hang out at the MC five house and go see the stooges.
I'm like,
you're killing me cause this is like,
you know,
I,
that would have been heaven for me to see those bands like back in 1969 or
whatever.
Did you,
when did you know him?
Did you know him back in the day or did you only to recently as a punter,
I would go see him like in high school and the 1870s you know,
Carter administration,
I'd go see him at play in my local arena in Washington DC in a place called the
Capitol Center in Largo,
Maryland.
And he was as good as rock and roll gets.
I mean it was,
I saw the,
the double I've guns old lineup and like forget it.
It was like two and a half hours of just getting beat up by music.
It was fantastic.
And to this day,
it's still a high watermark as far as the gigs.
And in the 90s I met him on politically incorrect Bill Maher and I said,
hey man,
I'm a big fan.
And he gave me a bow hunting catalog.
I'm like,
well thanks.
You know,
for his whack master,
right.
You know,
you get the croquet mallet and the,
anyway,
I kept it.
I told I'm a fan.
And then I met him years later,
uh,
and I do this radio show,
like Saint Patrick's Day in 1997 to crassly promote my next record.
And I said,
we met years ago and,
and we got to talking for like a couple of hours and we,
it was just about music and I played him some of my new record,
which you really liked.
And he,
between the commercial breaks,
he was like playing riffs for me.
We had a little headphone amp and he was sitting across from me on a stool
playing.
And I'm like,
this is pretty cool.
And so that's the kind of relationship I have with him where I,
you know,
you read some of the things he says,
you're like,
okay,
that's really hard to take and but those records,
you know,
they're just so good to me.
And I saw him play in 2000 opening for kiss 2001 somewhere in there and he was
great.
Great.
The tone,
the playing just fantastic.
And so he's just an interesting a bunch of guys,
a bunch of guys,
you know what I mean?
Cause like he can finish a sentence.
He's not,
he's not,
he's not stupid.
He's hilarious.
He has a steel trap memory.
But then he'll just say like,
you know the Obama's as subhuman Mongrel,
like man,
you don't need to talk like that because there's people you will inspire to
punch some black guy in the parking lot for no reason.
Like something bad could happen if you talk like that to the millions of people
who love you.
Like someone will get that message and they'll go south with it.
And when you're in that position,
I don't believe in self censorship,
but I think you should be careful of what you say.
I think there's some merit in having some control of yourself.
And so I don't completely understand the guy,
this currency and outrageousness that's what it is.
And you,
you cash in by being the guy that says things he can't,
I can't believe what he just said.
And then you become the guy that goes places that says things that no one can
believe that you're saying.
You know,
I,
I know that there's some people that's how they get their next book deal or
whatever.
For Myself,
I would never want to trade in that cause my,
my reality coming up through punk rock and all of that is very,
very immediate in that I don't say anything about anybody
without expecting them to hear it.
And with me turning the next corner,
like going to my car and your parking lot and having that person waiting for me
at the car saying,
Hey,
you said this,
and having the meal to hold it up on a,
on a tablet and say,
and so I watch what I say because in my mind I answer,
I will have to answer to all of it.
And so I would never say something where someone going to really quell.
Today's a day we're going to see who can kick,
who says ass.
Because you know men have this wrong idea that they can't be beat.
Are you kidding?
Anyone could get knocked on her ass.
You think you're tough.
There's always,
you know,
you're in the business of tough guys.
There's always a tougher guy around the corner,
the tougher guy.
But more than that,
it's like you don't,
most of the conflict that you get and when you talking shit about somebody,
like someone like you or I can do an interview and talk shit about someone and
it didn't go public and you don't think twice about it.
But then now it extends to social media.
Cause actually anybody could do it at any time.
And it just seems so easy to do.
But I always try to think if that person was in front of me,
how's that treat it?
And if I would,
if I would say,
fuck this guy,
like when he's in front of me,
then this is,
I have a real problem with this person.
It's a real bad.
But I would always wait until I was in front of that person and I have waited
and bided my time with people I don't like.
And you get into a conversation and all I have said very calmly,
I think you're a ridiculous person.
I think you're a standing,
walking,
talking billboard for cowardice.
Sometimes people need to hear that too because sometimes people don't hear that.
They don't hear that from someone.
I'm not going to help the guy,
but believe me.
But I waited until we were there.
The only people I'll rip on our politicians,
like some member of Congress,
I think is just an inactive waste of food.
Um,
that'll say anywhere hoping it'll bring him to me.
So I can say it to his or her face,
but for the most part,
the way I was brought up in the world of music and the street is if you say
something,
that guy will be lining you up for a broken jaw.
So you better mean it.
But maybe just wait until you guys are in a room and see what you really want to
say.
Cause Sniping from a windowless room from somewhere or being a a keyboard
activists.
Eh,
that's not,
that doesn't mean much to me.
Yeah.
I think you know,
ted is the spokesperson for the right in,
in that he's this contrast in so many ways.
He's this wild and it used to be long hair.
He doesn't have long hair anymore,
but long haired guitar player from Michigan,
I mean he's Ted Nugent.
He should be this,
he should be a drug user or something.
Right.
He should be on tour all the time.
But he's the opposite.
He was like,
doesn't do any drugs,
doesn't drink.
And he's super right wing and he supports,
you know,
the second amendment and guns and he,
there's,
he's in this group.
Have any as some very strong beliefs that he really does hold in that group,
but then comes the outrageous stuff that he says and you would get a
mischaracterization of him because of some of the things he says.
But if you meet like in person,
person,
a person,
he's a great guy.
Yeah,
I talked to him all the time that texting each other only been my experience
with,
he's a great guy is I've had really cool conversations with him and I'm a hyper
fan of the records.
I mean it's Gospel to me that those records are in my DNA and I don't effect,
I'm with you and that I don't know what fuels those and I just don't get it.
I'm not here to rip on him.
I just honestly do not,
I can't reconcile the conversations.
I had re super friendly and happy that you're a fan of the guy and then you,
you watched some things,
he says,
uh,
you know,
on some stage somewhere you're like,
wow,
that's,
that's as bummed that my whole evening that's like,
yeah,
okay.
Like that's you,
it's the first amendment.
Go do your thing.
But like,
wow,
that's.